[Music]
this morning on the dish
cheon famous foods the hand-pulled
noodles produced by this father-son team
have become
a sensation it's an authentic slice of
western china right here at home though
it's not necessarily the kind of chinese
food most people are used to eating
it's food native to the city where the
silk road started more than 2 000 years
ago
now featured in a new book for the duo
behind xi'an
it's both a passion and quite a
production
as we saw firsthand you're on the order
right
i got you come right up spend any time
with jason
wang and his family and it's never going
to be long before you hear the sound
of slapping noodles
from this time-honored exercise emerges
some of the best comfort food you'll
ever consume
but before we get too far with the
demonstration the origin story
when jason was just a small child his
dad david moved the family to the united
states from china
for years his father toiled as an
itinerant cook in kitchens all over the
northeast
until 15 years ago when he decided to
open his own restaurant
people say hole in the wall like it's a
small restaurant but the hole in the
wall we're talking about is a literal
outside out like a little hole on the
sidewalk on the side of the building
next to the bus station flushing the q
58. your dad's out here
like documenting the whole yes
documenting the process
yeah he loves it he loves to see you
know professionals at work
it's fun it's fun and he opened a place
and didn't tell you about it
yeah he's a man of surprises the
surprise of his dad secretly opening a
restaurant became even more real for
wang not long after
as he writes in his new book cheyenne
famous foods
the cuisine of western china from new
york's favorite noodle shop
i joined the business 2009 uh fresh out
of school
i was you know now the book is out
basically i could stay i was fired you
know i was fired out of school
for my first job you know i was like oh
man life is over right
but at the same time i felt like maybe
it was meant to happen
jason went to work for his father after
his dad moved into a slightly larger
space
before long there was something about
the family dynamic and the food
that caught the eye of the late anthony
bourdain this place was unbelievable
this place is
great bourdain showed up one day
unannounced to film an episode of his
show no reservations
and loved it i've never had anything
like this before i've tasted these
flavors but i've never had this
within the framework of chinese xi'an
named after the ancient chinese city
was a hit even though many people didn't
understand exactly what kind of food
they were eating
people know beijing they know shanghai
xi'an has
four million more people than new york
city and a lot of people don't know it's
there
yeah i mean it's actually a very
important city in china it's
historically significant because that
city is
home of 13 dynasties of imperial china
ancient china
and there's a lot of history there a lot
of landmarks
and a lot of culture the famed silk road
started in xi'an
and the food wang serves as heavy on
noodles not the rice most people are
used to seeing in dishes from southern
china
the art of pulling and slapping noodles
can take a lifetime to master
but it only takes a few seconds to learn
these are our pieces of dough
that we made from just a big block of
dill yeah it's been made to the right
consistency covered with oil
we're just going to put a piece one
piece like this flat on the surface
there
take the roller that you got these
skinny rollers work the best better than
those big you know baking rollers
um so just not don't press too hard but
just kind of flatten it
slightly so it's like a big rectangle
now and then just
indent the middle just slightly mine
looks like massachusetts
instead of a rectangle it's a good state
so
okay you're good all right okay so then
just take this piece off peel it off of
the board
grab the two sides but don't pinch too
hard like kind of like this
okay yeah just don't squeeze too hard
and start pulling it apart
like this when you get to be about
shoulder width or a little bit more
you can start you know using the board
as a guide to kind of slap it
so it's going to be more more in the uh
like the arms a little bit a little in
the wrist and you look much more artful
doing this
you know yeah table's a little low but
oh i just hit myself in the face oh no
that's part of the fun
after about three to five minutes in
boiling water hand ripped
noodles are ready in this case had to be
served with a chian favorite
spicy cumin lamb also dished up for us
stewed pork burgers a spicy asian salad
with crunchy spiny cucumbers
red braised pork spare ribs and long pea
cold skin noodles a cheon vegan favorite
all of these have attributed to our
brand's success
and i owe a lot of gratitude to all of
them there is one
catch with the xi'an noodles you cannot
get them delivered
now i tried to get delivery
[Laughter]
and you wouldn't do it i couldn't i
won't
okay i won't bring you cooked noodles
jeff there's i just can't do it it's
real
call me stubborn but i just cannot have
cooked noodles that it's gonna congeal
into this like doughy lasagna looking
mess
and have that be the first impression
that you have with your family you know
i think that
for me um you know noodles don't travel
after 10-15 minutes i wouldn't even you
know myself i would throw it out
as a substitute these days wang is
shipping out meal kits
so you can make the noodles fresh at
home
keep going trust us it's
fun other parts of our current situation
for wang and others are not the pandemic
has forced them to close
four of their 14 locations but if our
taste test is any indication
so good oh my gosh when all this is over
all those places
will come ripping right back it's a
constant struggle i think you know
tweaking the way that we're working
uh with the situation and that's
something that
i guess we kind of enjoy you know the
american dream is an ongoing thing
it's not just you reach it and you're
done you know i think it's an ongoing
maintenance
and a way of living and eating and
eating of course
living and eating yum
right my health is so good so because
the noodles don't travel well as we say
uh i didn't bring some here but they're
arriving this afternoon for both of you
are bouncing like i expect to see
either tonight slap in my face while
we're watching it
baby so we'll share those videos next
week so while we're watching football
tonight
make noodles make some noodles